hey David we've heard about the start of
Paul's missionary activity the so called
first mr. missionary journey when he was
on Cyprus and then in Asia Minor
culminating and they counted they at the
Jerusalem conference and the decision to
allow Gentiles into this this movement
without becoming Jews and now we have in
this next couple of chapters 16 and 17
the bulk of what counts as Paul's second
missionary journey and to flip I write
and there he does a number of things
including to convert a woman a woman
named Lydia what do you make of her and
what do you make of that well what
strikes me is that in some ways as these
are the case in Paul's letters you have
a sense that women have some importance
in the early poll on community she's
clearly a person of substance because we
heard not only about her but about our
household we don't we don't know many of
the details of her life but I think in
some ways it's consistent with what we
see in some of the letters where Paul
clearly will greet women or talk about
women we've talked about Philippians you
and I together before and the whole
purpose of Philippians is to work out
some kind of dispute in the church and
it seems to be related to a dispute
between two women leaders you audience
in deke who are clearly important enough
that their dispute brings to stress on
the whole congregation so I think acts
begins to mirror that sense that the
right reminiscence that what women had
have been important part in the early
Christian communities did you remember
where Lydia was from originally theater
as I remember it yeah where do we hear
about that book of Revelation do you
think there's any connection there no
idea mmm gonna be interesting yeah well
what yeah if we invited you well in
Revelation we look at that see if
theater was purple in those do you think
that people like Lydia play a role in
the pages of Luke analogous to the role
played by the women in poles actually
I'm better thinking about that with the
with the Gospel of Luke that I amiable
with acts because I've been influenced
by a woman named sure and ringy who
teaches in Washington DC and who wrote
the the commentary we use in the series
on acts in fact and says that women are
important but subordinate consist
that the the Mary and Martha story and
nuke is kind of a paradigm of the role
that women have in Luke and acts which
is a welcome to serve and they're
welcome to listen but they're not in the
same way leaders of the church that they
really seem to be in some of Paul's
writings in Paul's writings one get a
sense that these are these are apostles
and ministers and deacons and important
leading figures of the church not simply
servant figures yeah and that would
comport with what Lydia does he or she
provides hospitality he doesn't preach
yeah and the next woman we meet in the
next episode is a slave girl not so good
yeah yeah needs to be delivered from her
or being possessed though as often the
case in Luke's Gospel the slave girl
says the right thing for the wrong
reasons that is right she she she claims
the two of them as being what's the word
in there she's got it anyway claims for
them their rule is poor clear up who
proclaimed you the way of salvation
slaves the most high to proclaim the
reservation that's true they are that
but she's saying it for the wrong reason
under a spirit of divination so she has
to be exercised and then we have another
episode where we have an imprisonment
and some rather remarkable escape from
yeah and as part of that whole episode
we we learned that Paul at least and
probably Barnabas of Roman citizens yes
what do you make of that claim loop well
in there there clearly was a category of
people in that time who became citizens
of Rome not because they had grown up as
kind of Italians but who in various ways
were were brought into the Roman Empire
and one of those ways was through the
citizenship bestowed on certain freed
persons freedmen and then apparently on
their heirs as well and we'll see later
that one of the jailers I think contrast
himself to Paul by saying he bought a
citizenship and Paul just got his which
makes me think that Paul may well have
inherited this through the family and it
becomes very important because those who
imprisoned Paul are not allowed to treat
him as a Roman citizen as they would
worry simply a kind of
an odd woman citizen right right yeah so
that might be a historical detail astral
detail that has write it all it also
fits I think what are the concerns we've
seen all along which is I think on the
whole this on the whole this book is
written to help Christians feel good
about Rome and Rome feel good about
Christians and if you see our key figure
already lives in both worlds then the
kind of contrast between being Roman and
being Christian diminishes becomes very
important toward the end of Acts okay so
they move on beyond Philippi and move to
Thessalonica or another city in
Macedonia and there they do what Paul
usually does when he goes into a place
he starts his his evangelistic activity
what does that look like well we start
he starts with the synagogue and then
tends not to be accepted very well there
and then moves on to the larger
community and in a way I think I'd love
to get your responses as I was thinking
about this to get ready for our
conversation it's almost a kind of
miniature version of what happens in the
whole gospel of Acts that you start with
Jerusalem and move to Rome you start
with a set a move to the Genda community
start with Peter preaching good Jews and
with Paul preaching to Gentiles and x17
it reflects one may be very historically
accurate to I think reflects kind of the
movement of the way the god spirit is
starting with Israel but not ending with
Israel and maybe we'll see when we get
to chapter 28 saying that's over I don't
know but it's part of a path and whether
Paul's practice was as schematic and as
systematic it works great yeah one
interesting little tidbit in
Thessalonica obviously there's a little
bit of disturbance when Paul and his
friends started to preach and the folk
react and say these people are turning
the world upside down
this isn't 17-6 yeah and then go on to
say that they think there's another king
yeah named Jesus so what do you make of
this and the larger framework of Paul of
Luke's apologetic when quick aside I
just been reading the biography of
George Washington
story is that when the British
surrendered at Yorktown they played a
tune on their pipes and drums called the
world turned upside down and it's a
little bit of that he who was King his
King no longer and I think I think
Luke's in a tricky position he wants to
say that the true king is Jesus on the
other hand he was to say that's not
really a threat to Caesar because you
can't worship Caesar but you can live
with Caesar and I suspect this is one of
those little passages where you're
trying to play both those things off
each other yes the world that turned
upside down but don't get too worried
governor we're not actually going to
come and take over the portrait a little
bit analogous I think to what we were
talking about in one of our early
conversations on the book of Acts on the
issue of wealth and poverty yeah well
Luke articulation yeah in its ideal
ideal form the world is totally turned
upside down in the time between till
Christ comes to reign in victory we kick
their world around a little bit but
we're not yet quite in the revolutionary
mode it reminds me of the Magnificat the
buddy yeah yeah but they had but not
quite you have so Paul's itinerary takes
him through Macedonia Philippi
Thessalonica as we can reconstruct them
as epistles next to Athens yeah and this
is a very interesting episode isn't it I
think hugely important it's the only
extended speech in Acts where Paul
doesn't presuppose a certain amount of
scriptural knowledge on the part of
those who are listening to him but
assumes that these are people whose
background whose sociology of knowledge
does not include being steeped in the
Hebrew Scriptures and so he draws on
things that they would know as opposed
to trying to draw on his own Pharisaic
background right Luke characterizes them
in acts 17 18 is epicurean and stoic
philosophers who are debating with Paul
do you think that this this speech that
is attributed to Paul really addresses
stoic and epicurean oh you're much
better at this than I am I think I hear
in that I hear in the first part of it
about the creator of the world and the
way in which we can somehow know that
God through our
it's certainly kind of stoic echoes I'm
much less there about whether the direct
epicurean echoes and I'm much less clear
about whether Paul is saying these are
kind of card-carrying epicurean and
stoic services kind of here too big here
are two big philosophical groups at the
time these are just thinking people what
do you think I think that they're
analogous to the the bumpkins of Asia -
hold
yes their stock capital stock characters
and as you say there's a little bit of
almost explicit snow especially when the
poet probably era this is being cited in
acts 17:28 for we too are his offs
the offspring of the whoa whoa yeah or
they the grand spirit whatever yeah that
would be something that a good stoic
would say it's not something an
epicurean would say right right was more
gracious than right and then they have a
career injury yeah but in its entirety
of philosophical speech art there's a
kind of gesture at the beginning to a
natural philosophy no I think it's I
think I mean gestures just the right
word I think the what happens at the
beginning you all remember is he talks
about how we are somehow constructed in
God's image and therefore idolatry can't
be right because idolatry makes gods
look less than we and the God who is our
God must be more than we and there's a
kind of echo in here of chapter 1 of
Romans where Paul talks about when you
look around the world if you pay
attention even though you don't have the
law of Moses you have the law written on
your hearts but it doesn't end there he
moves he moves toward the end toward the
resurrection which does not fit any kind
of natural theology and says that this
is finally what's going to have to
convict people and I suspect I have no
idea of what the historical Paul did I
think that's still often pretty good
preaching that pretty good preaching
starts with people in their situation
and with the kind of philosophical
presuppositions with which we live and
then at the end you still have to name
Jesus and say finally we're not going to
get there by philosophy alone and
there's a call to repentance motives and
also eschatological judgment and the
claim that judgment is coming and some
believe and some don't
which sounds to me almost certainly
pretty accurate right right and
interesting enough these philosophers
including someone called dietitian area
becomes a fictional character later on
in the history of theology right they
all think that Paul is talking about
some some deity named resurrection angel
yes exactly because the the Greek word
resurrections female looks like you've
got a male God and a female God kind of
like Isis and Osiris so the one
interesting little twist is that these
sophisticated philosophers are making a
mistake very similar the country
bumpkins they categorical mistake very
nice yeah once again put the make the
make the wise look foolish exactly
Romans again yep first Corinthians okay